what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to king von
armed and dangerous before i start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos um just you guys know
i'm not really into rap music but i do
it for you guys uh someone would be
giving my
educated interpretation production
okay i bet this is symbolism right in
the beginning
he's taking out the trash so he's saying
i'm gonna take out
the trashy women in my life just just uh
my guess
[Music]
[Music]
okay i'm already bopping oh my gosh this
is a bop so he's saying
that
the police are looking for him but he
keeps his gun on him to keep himself
safe um
in the most respectful way possible i
believe that he died so clearly not that
safe but
you know i mean we can't all live up to
the lyrics
[ __ ] that i can't even remember but they
remember me [ __ ] that happened later
december i bring that winner [ __ ] down
the whole october the real halloween
back to back funerals is them my
assistant don't get booked cause
[Music]
[Music]
um
he said rip
so i'm thinking there's some people
dying i don't know
21-45 i'm like what the [ __ ] that means
you fighting the armed robbery shorty
that's what they offer my little brother
getting big my uncle got that cough
again he'd been smoking cracks since i
was born that monkey smoking him i used
to stay up late at granny crib just to
talk to him when i was locked i got
knocked on his door and told him what
would happen back to this chilling [ __ ]
social started rapping now the world's
going firing
[Music]
[Music]
um so he's saying if you mess up you
might get left um
that's not a nice message i'm not a fan
of that
you're my son i'm your dad you my son
i'm your daddy
steady watching me every day they
coughing red alert i'm the dangerous
oh i just got it
i'm not talking so he's saying like
he did all the the tragedies and oh my
gosh
wow um okay that was an interesting song
um
i'm gonna give that so okay i'm not even
gonna lie i was bopping my head like
the
the beat like bopped i it bopped but
like
overall i didn't really appreciate the
message of the song i'll give it a six
out of actually i like to do one to five
skills so i'll give it a three out of
five three out of five let me know in
the comments if you guys agree or you
disagree don't forget to subscribe love
you